cvpr forbids tweeting about papers ai is
used to restore a rembrandt
and a potential deep fake has big
consequences in the country of myanmar
welcome to this week's ml news
hello and welcome to ml news you're
absolutely
regular every week on monday update on
what's going on
in the machine learning world the first
one
fresh of the press walter shirer writes
the result of the cvpr 2021
pommy tc votes are in all four motions
passed this decides over the future of
the cvpr conference in the next few
years
now you can see the motions here and
particularly interesting
is motion number four social media
limitation during
review overwhelmingly accepted this
motion was proposed by michael black
and says social media promotion of
papers is prohibited
during the review period for cvpr except
for automatic posting of new preprints
by
archive so essentially means during the
review period you're not allowed to go
and tweet about your papers you're only
allowed to upload them to archive and
there is an exception because
archive sometimes automatically tweets
new papers anything else
no go now there is a bit of an outrage
about this i have to say
it's not as big of a rule change as it
seems so the reasoning behind this is
there already used to be a
press release ban during the review
period and this motion simply extends
the press release ban
to social media because effectively
while you couldn't do a press release
you could still
tweet about your papers and get the word
out this way the big concern here is
that groups with a lot of following or a
lot of press influence
will have their papers exposed to more
people which could bias the review
process
now in the light of already existing
press ban extending the ban to social
media
makes sense however i feel the bigger
issue is why
is there a press ban at all why aren't
you allowed to talk about your papers as
they are under review
so the argumentation of the proposal is
that this can bias the reviewer's
judgment
if they're exposed to this work now as
much as i like the idea of peer review
it's really not working currently they
say peer review is the backbone of
science the process helps detect
mistakes or false claims before the work
appears in public
yeah right when has this happened the
last time i've exposed more false claims
on my channel
than the entire zvpr conference in the
review process
we have to get away from this notion
that peer review is adequately
constituted by
three dudes sitting on the toilet whilst
flicking through your paper on their
smartphone and then giving a weak reject
i argue that social media is the actual
peer review
what seems weird to me is that they have
sort of an faq here
answering some of the worries about this
so there are questions why won't this
slow down scientific
progress and what about archive and
their claim here is that no this won't
slow down scientific progress
because experts in the field make
scientific progress
not the general public and here again
archive tweets are largely followed by
experts in the field and not the general
public
wait i thought the peer review was
supposed to be experts
aren't the peer reviewers exactly the
people who would follow the archive
publications like if it was just a
general public receiving the social
media posts
why are we worried after all experts
make the contributions in the scientific
field not the general public the truth
is that currently social media
imperfect unbalanced with different
followings as it is constitutes a much
more rigorous peer review process
than what we have at conferences the
social network that we've built up
online effectively highlights
interesting papers
and yes a lot of them come from big
companies but let's face it they have
really good researchers and a lot of
resources but often it happens enough
that some no-name paper gets surfaced
because it is interesting whereas in the
conference proceedings it would just get
lost
this is in the light of other
conferences doing things like
archive blackouts before submitting and
people calling for
entirely banning archive uploads before
conferences
all of this is highly suspicious now who
is really profiting from the current
system and who's really going to lose
from a more
open approach to publishing it's going
to be people that take part in the
nice little collusion rings that we have
these are people publishing dozens and
dozens and dozens of paper each year in
some niche field where everyone knows
everyone and everyone knows who
everyone's paper is from and they just
kind of accept each other however when
the public encounters these papers
they're generally
boring not interesting and don't
actually contribute anything to the
knowledge of humankind
so yeah if research is more in public
that's not gonna fly anymore which is a
good thing
so future cvpr submitters all to
youtubers inboxes are at your
disposal enough of us are bribable so
you still have good outlets if you have
money well won't that tilt the balance
even more into the direction of big
corporations so in conclusions
conferences
are hell-bent on making themselves not
important even faster than they already
are next news supermarket news writes
walmart enlists artificial intelligence
for online grocery substitutions so this
is actually pretty interesting
in that walmart has people going around
shopping for you so you place an online
order and these people go
and they buy stuff for you however
sometimes items are out of stock and
when that happens
a substitution needs to happen so
walmart apparently has built some sort
of a recommender system
that tells these shoppers which product
they can substitute
i originally thought this was a pretty
simple problem like oh we don't have
this milk have this other milk but it
seems to be
that it's not that easy and they claim
since deploying the ai
solution customer acceptance of online
grocery substitutions has climbed over
so good for them real world problem ai
solves it
all good is this a marketing piece
absolutely but still
kind of cool okay nvidia
releases alias free gam and this fixes
the supposed problem
of the strong dependence of gans on the
exact coordinates of the pixels now i
won't go through the paper here
but you should look at these
visualizations they're pretty pretty
cool
so on the left you see the old style gun
and it's so freaky look at the hair
it kind of stays in place while the face
goes around well of course their method
fixes this particular problem here's the
same it just kind of looks like a head
that's kind of sliding
under a foreground layer of of hair
what's also praised about the new model
is the sort of better interpolations
that you can see
right here and again you can see the
less dependence on the actual pixel
coordinates
particularly impressive i find to be
this beach interpolation where you can
see stalgan
just kind of keeps everything at the
same place
ish while as the alias-free gam tends to
move around a lot now whether these are
cherry-picked or not
and whether in the final analysis the
alias-free gan is really better than the
style gun
who knows safe to say when it comes to
gans we are
pushing the limits of what's doable and
we are really getting into the
territories of fine-tuning these things
hard to believe that like five years ago
we could barely make a face
[Music]
speaking of gans apparently in the
country of myanmar
there is a confession video going around
of a politician confessing to
transferring some money and due to
artifacts in the video
people claim it's a deep fake now this
article here
explores this claim and comes to the
conclusion that
probably the artifacts are more a
compression artifact because the video
is very low quality but it does raise
important questions as if we get better
and better and better at producing
realistic looking images sound and video
in the future we'll have to develop
new expectations of what counts as real
evidence of something happening
a video of you saying something or doing
something might no longer be enough as
you could just always claim that is a
deep fate now i wouldn't be so overly
worried about this because we have the
same situation
right now with writing if i simply claim
to you
that a certain person who recently
passed away and once founded an
anti-virus company has sent me an email
briefly before his death and the email
said certain things i could even present
you the email on a sheet of paper
yet you wouldn't necessarily believe me
so what we'll have to change is just our
expectations of which mediums
are valid forms of evidence and not
easily tampered with i don't know what's
going to be the solution in the future
but i'm sure we'll come up with
something
[Music]
smithsonian magazine writes lost edges
of rembrandt's night watch are restored
using
artificial intelligence apparently this
painting had been cut at some point to
hang it on some wall
and the cuts have been lost now
artificial intelligence has been used to
restore this painting
how nice so apparently this is a
multi-million dollar restoration project
and at the same time it seems like a
really really concerted effort but also
from what they tell it it also seems
like you could do it in five minutes
on one hand the input data seems to be
really rich so there is
x-ray scanners 528 digital exposures
and so on on the other hand they write
things like though many museums employ
painters to reconstruct masterworks the
senior scientist robert erdmann was able
to use
a computer to recreate the missing
panels computer
so they apparently they use this new
technology called convolutional
neural networks a type of artificial
intelligence algorithm that helps
computers figure
out what images may have once looked
like
okay the crux of the thing now comes
when they say apparently there is a
copy of the original painting that sort
of shows what it should look like
so essentially what these researchers
did appears to be something like
a sophisticated style transfer where
they use the
copy of the image as a base and then
transfer the style of rembrandt on top
of it
now this is both pretty cool in that we
now have technology that can do these
things
but we also have to be honest about what
this is this is a believable
way this could have looked like there's
no way of knowing if rembrandt actually
drew
this particular thing or something else
that resulted in the same copy of this
other painter
in any case the picture is now complete
thanks to computer
thanks computer okay greenville business
magazine writes prisma health announces
artificial intelligence partnership to
make doctors
more efficient to inform them with their
decisions and so on and
at the same time verge rights a hospital
algorithm designed
to predict a deadly condition misses
most cases
and it also had many false alarms so the
algorithm was tasked with detecting
sepsis a complicated condition that can
bring patients into critical state
now the way this was trained was with
data labeled
not whether the patient has sepsis or
not but whether the doctor
would submit a bill for treatment of
sepsis so essentially it's trying to
replicate what the doctors do
and not actually predict the patient's
state i get that this
is easier labels than actually figuring
out what happened but also don't be
surprised if then it doesn't work better
than the doctors they say it's
essentially trying to predict what
physicians are already doing suffice to
say
while ai is a powerful tool that can
definitely
help with many things we still have to
be careful when we deploy it in the real
world and actually measure its
performance and given that this article
exists performance has been measured
and we're going to go back to the
drawing board
chip yen and others release a book
called introduction to machine learning
interviews the book
is mostly for interviewees but also for
interviewers to prepare
for machine learning interviews so if
you have an interview
soon or if you're looking to interview
someone this might be a nice resource
for you the book is free and available
give it a try
it might just get you a job
as fast as one can go turn sketches into
stunning landscapes with nvidia canvas
written by nvidia so nvidia has released
this new application called
canvas in which you're able to sort of
draw a doodle
and it will transform it into really
nice looking pictures
this is part of the nvidia sort of
artist suite
that helps people be more creative i
guess
or less or differently i'm not sure how
to characterize this
the canvas app is available as a beta
you can download it
if you do have a nvidia graphics card i
believe
i haven't tried it out myself because
all the graphics card i have access to
don't actually have a monitor on them
so what do i do speaking of gpus
good news for deep learners as the
register writes now that china has all
but banned cryptocurrencies gpu prices
are falling like bitcoin
so china hasn't fully banned
cryptocurrencies but is cracking down
majorly on them and that means that some
of the
mining power is going away and with it
the gpu demand is lower than it used to
be so if you wanted to buy yourself a
data center
now might be the time
[Music]
facebook is looking to make your
shopping experience
easier using ai they have a selection of
software
called product match that helps identify
products from
pictures among other things so this
allows sellers to tag their products
easily but it also allows you to find
products that you see somewhere or on
someone so artificial intelligence might
help you
with shopping in the future and i can't
wait to see
all the adversarial attacks on these
systems yes for sure i'm gonna sell you
a rolex it's right here
the ai system even says it's one three
thousand bucks thank you
google ai releases deep lab 2 for
tensorflow which is a library to do
pixel based segmentation or any sort of
pixel-based labeling task so this is on
github you can go
check it out if you are in that space it
seems like
it's a good code base if you're in the
research directions or tasks of
pixel-based labeling such as semantic
segmentation
or textual labeling or explainable ai
give it a look all right besides all the
news i feel we should also cover some
non-news so i've seen this paper
de-experts decoding time control text
generation with
experts and anti-experts now this seems
to be
a good paper as far as i can tell it
takes on the tasks of
mitigating toxicity in language
generation
so as you can see right here you have
some sort of a base language model
that has some output and then you have
what they call the
experts and some of them are non-toxic
and some of them
are deliberately toxic and by
contrasting non-toxic experts and the
toxic
experts you can then make sure that you
re-weigh the outputs towards
a non-toxic behavior now i've got
nothing
against this paper however what i want
to say is that
this is like a 100 recipe
of making a super toxic language model
all i have to do is flip
this one sign right here i can just take
whatever this
is i can flip one bit in the algorithm
and i make the most
toxic language model ever to the big
credits of the authors this is even
acknowledged in the broader impact
statement they say we acknowledge that
any controllable detoxification method
runs the risk of dual use specifically
this technology could be used to
automatically generate
hateful texts for a broader discussion
of such risks and the risks of large
pre-trained language models in general
please see the stochastic parrots paper
now there are enough people
that with every face upsampling method
cry that we shouldn't develop these
things and all of this is dangerous
it should be measured by the harm it
causes and so on and here i have a
method that flipping one
single bit will make it super duper
toxic and harmful
is there anyone complaining about this
paper no
zero where are these people are you
really telling me that a little
paragraph in the broader impact
statement is gonna not cause the harm
now i think i know how this works
because
we gave the proper citation we have the
proper friends we frame it in the proper
way
and the narrative uphold so in my
personal opinion
we should not give too much power to
these ethics people
unless papers like this one are met with
at least as much scrutiny
as the papers they're usually
criticizing again i'm totally fine with
this paper then again
i'm also totally fine with pretty much
all the other papers i'm just calling
for a bit of consistency here
[Music]
okay last news a deal in beatrice in
analytics inside rights
yes artificial intelligence can't do
these things
it's an article about what artificial
intelligence isn't able to do
and also a bit of an argument of why it
won't be able to do it
in the near future among these things is
the classic
use common sense to make decisions
argument and
i love the example that they give right
here for example if we say
a woman went shopping she bought a
beautiful dress she left
the place with a big smile if asked what
the woman shopped a human would
instantly say
a beautiful dress but answering these
simple questions
is very difficult for artificial
intelligence
all right hold on here's gptj of eluther
ai
a woman went chopping she bought a
beautiful dress she'll have to place
with a big smile
now she wants to return her purchase off
and the model says
the dress she wants her money back
totally lacking common sense i get it is
just one example
but i think there are much more
effective ways to criticize artificial
intelligence than it doesn't have common
sense like if common sense is sort of
your
intuitive gut feeling of things like it
has common sense
[Music]
all right this was it for this week's ml
news how did you do today did you win
did you lose did you even know there was
a game involved who knows
we'll be here next week at monday nine
o'clock
no questions asked take care